fox news alert a major update in the
gabby potato case the fbi confirming
that the remains found in yes found
yesterday in florida are indeed brian
laundry's
all right uh let's take this around the
table degan
uh not surprised how they were
discovered was a little fishy yes they
said that they had been under what the
area had been under water and then the
water receded and they discovered the
belongings and now his body what's
unfortunate for gabby petito's family is
he will never face a jury there will
never be uh punishment for this he's
dead and there's no prosecution
oh wait let's go to phil keating he
might have some information phil you
there
i am here i did confirm earlier this
late afternoon that the skeletal remains
were actually just bones that's what the
human remains were but at that point we
still did not know the identity of whose
bones they were then about 5 15 across
town over at the laundry home an
unmarked car pulled up a couple of fbi
agents went in for about three or four
minutes and then just minutes ago the
fbi denver which has been leading the
fbi's investigation due to its proximity
and control over the happenings in
wyoming where gabby petito's body was
discovered they tweeted out and i will
quote to you exactly what they wrote a
comparison of dental records confirmed
that the human remains found
are those of brian laundry steve
bertolino the often quoted attorney for
the parents chris and roberta laundry
has also put out a short note saying the
parents have been notified we have no
further comment at this time please
respect their privacy so the national
manhunt for brian laundry is now
officially over it was in fact his human
remains found here yesterday inside the
uh nature park where he had been told uh
by his mom and dad to the fbi that this
is where he went off for a hike as he
frequently did two days after gabby
petito was finally reported missing up
in suffolk county new york by her mother
after not hearing from her for weeks and
weeks and of course brian laundry
returned home from that big summer long
road trip out west at all the national
parks without gabby petito what he told
his parents to explain why she was gone
nobody knows but the family did go
camping following weekend up outside of
tampa and they've been under
investigation but they
probably won't be charged at all now
that their son is dead and there's no
way to contradict anything they had
shared wow but brian laundry is dead
thanks phil all right